NAVNEET JONEJA: My name
is Navneet Joneja.
I'm the product manager for
Google Cloud Storage.
With me is Nathan Herring,
an engineer on the team.
And we're here to talk to you
about how you can use Google
Cloud Storage to power your
application's data.
So a quick overview of what
we're going to talk about
today, we're going to start
off by talking about Cloud
Storage in general and why it's
an interesting set of
tools for a large number
of applications.
We'll spend some time diving
into Cloud Storage as a
service and its benefits.
And then finally we'll talk
about several advanced use
cases in the context of an
application that you might
build yourself.
So while you're watching this
talk, we hope you'll ask
yourself just one question which
is, what could you do
with your applications
if you had access to
storage as a service?
If you knew that your data was
always available and had great
performance because it was
backed by the same
infrastructure that Google uses
for its own applications,
and was backed by 99.9% SLA--
if you could get the benefit of
transparent scaling built
on the same infrastructure that
lets YouTube handle over
60 hours of video uploads every
minute, and if it's cost
effective as well?
Because you only paid for what
you used, so you didn't have
to worry about buying a large
amount of storage hardware in
advance, planning your capacity,
worrying about what
happens if you bought too little
storage, which means
that you might have to scramble
to get more capacity.
Or the worst case scenario,
maybe even scale down what
you're doing, because
your infrastructure
can't support it.
On the flip side, by too much
and have a large amount of
unused capacity sitting
around costing money.
You don't have to worry about
either of those use cases,
because with storage as a
service you just pay for what
you use, and it's only cents
for the gigabytes.
So it's quite cost effective.
If you're like a lot of our
customers, we hope that you'll
find that having access to
service like this means that
you can focus on building the
application, and leave the
infrastructure, the scaling,
the performance
availability to Google.
Let's talk about the
foundations.
At its core, Google Cloud
Storage is a service that lets
you store your data on Google's
infrastructure, as I
mentioned, with very high
availability and performance
and reliability.
And that's primarily because
it's built on great
Infrastructure.
But also because we replicate
data, we have multiple layers
of redundancy.
So we have data replicated
across data centers, as well
as within the data center to
make sure that your data is
both durable and reliable.
And in fact, even if we were to
lose a data center, which
does that happen every now
and then the world--
an amusing anecdote I heard was
a garbage truck crashing
into a pole, knocking over an
optical fiber, and cutting the
data center off for
a few minutes.
But in general this stuff
happens, and you want to make
sure that if you're building an
application that faces end
users, that you don't have to
worry about this stuff.
It turns out that because
of the replication, the
redundancy, with Cloud Storage
you don't have to worry about
issues like that.
I also would like to mention
that with Google Cloud
Storage, we offer two different
regions, one in the
US and one in Europe.
And both of those are backed
by the same kind of
infrastructure, so multiple
layers of redundancy.
And it's powered by the
Google network.
So Google has spent more than
a decade building out a very
reliable, high performance,
highly available network,
because we need that for search,
for YouTube, for all
the other sites we serve.
And we put the same network to
work for you and your data
when you store your data
in cloud storage.
And you'll find very quickly--
and you may already
have found--
that when you trust your
applications, your data to the
cloud, that one of the
most important
things is the network.
Because ultimately it defines
the kind of performance, the
kind of experience you
get from the cloud.
And so we think that our
innovation and our constant
focus on the reliability and
quality of the network really
shows in all our services
and in Cloud
Service Storage as well.
And then finally, I talked a
little bit about scaling.
With Cloud Storage you can
store any amount of data.
So as you find new reasons to
gather data or store data in
the Cloud, you can just
stick it in the cloud.
And you can store up to five
terabytes per piece of data.
So you effectively
get access to
virtually unlimited scaling.
So I'm going to pause there
and stop talking about the
service, and actually show you
the service in action.
It's extremely easy to sign
up for the service.
All you do is you go to
developers.google.com/console,
which is the API's console.
If you've used any Google API,
you've been here before.
If not, that's the URL.
So you go there, and you turn on
the Cloud Storage API, and
that's pretty much it.
Because it's a paid service, if
you haven't entered billing
information in the past, it
will ask you for billing
information, and then
you're good to go.
So once you do that, you
actually already have access.
I've done that already here
in the background.
You can actually access all the
information need to access
Cloud Storage right here from
within the console.
And then let me show you
what that looks like.
So the Cloud Storage Service
actually has a RESTful API.
What I'm going to be showing
you is two tools that we've
built ourselves using the API.
You can replicate all this
functionality yourself, but we
find that for our users these
two tools are very easy and
very good ways to get started.
I'm going to start by showing
you a tool called gsutil.
And because I don't trust my
typing powers, I have put a
little shell script, but that's
what it looks like.
So it's a very, very familiar
looking tool.
It looks almost like
a Unix copy.
You're copying a bunch
of data from a folder
on the local directory.
I actually have a bunch
of data in a
folder called Assets.
And what I am actually
uploading is
JavaScript web game.
So I'm going to take an entire
JavaScript web game, and stick
it in the cloud right now.
I'm going to stick it in the
second part, which looks like,
basically, a URL.
It's a bucket, which
is a container for
storage in Cloud Storage.
And so what I'm going to do
right here is kick that off.
And while it's happening, I'm
going to show you the second
tool, which is the Cloud
Storage Manager.
And this is a very simple, basic
Web UI which lets you
get data into and out
of the cloud.
And we find that for early
tasks, when you're just
getting started with the
service, a lot of users will
come and start off here.
It doesn't offer all the
capabilities of the
Command Line Tool.
This is more for quickly getting
started, quickly
looking at your data.
I'm guessing that by now all
the data is already in the
cloud, so let me click through
on the bucket, and
there you have it.
So let me talk quickly about one
more piece of secret sauce
in here before I show you
the tool in action.
So all the data's copied
to the cloud.
If you recall, the URL actually
looked like a
website, www.gcsdemo.org.
That's because, actually,
I own that domain.
I've created CNAME redirect
to Cloud Storage.
So that domain is actually
going to be
served from Cloud Storage.
And so we do a little bit of
work behind the scenes.
It's not a lot of work, but I
kind of want to talk about it,
because it's both a benefit,
and it's a
little bit more work.
But we actually ask you to prove
that you own a domain.
If you create a bucket which
looks like a domain, we ask
that you prove that you own the
domain, and that's done
through the standard Google
Webmaster Tools.
So it's very simple to prove
it, and once you do that
you're the only person who can
actually create that domain.
And to prove that, I've created
an alternate config
with a different user
who doesn't
actually own the domain.
And I'm going to try and create
that random bucket in
the same domain.
Oops, no bucket for you.
So it's very easy to reserve
a domain that you own, so
there's no squatting.
You prove you own the domain,
you can create
buckets in that domain.
So now let me show you that
web game in action.
You can see the URL is
just www.gcsdemo.org.
And here is the game.
Of course, I'm actually better
at desktop pool that I am at
real pool, because that would
never have happened.
So as I mentioned, you can
build new applications.
That's just a very small
taste of what you can
do with Cloud Storage.
It's often a very easy getting
started thing, and people
often start off by trying to
serve data, but they quickly
learn that they could do a lot
more with the RESTful API.
So let's talk about
the service.
As I mentioned, it's
a RESTful API.
The model for how you store data
in the cloud is a very
fact, one level hierarchy based
on collections of data
called buckets and objects.
So anybody bucket can contain
a number of objects.
Buckets are sort of a nice one
level of hierarchy, so you can
share common configuration
things across objects, group
them, create a name space
for yourself.
Nathan will spend some more time
talking about some of the
cool things you can do when you
actually have a bucket.
So once you've created a bucket
and you have your data
in the cloud, we want to make
sure that you have very easy
access to it.
So we've provided you with
mechanisms to stream your data
into and out of the cloud.
So you don't necessarily have
to worry about gathering all
the data on your server, and
then forwarding it to us.
You can actually store your data
in the cloud as soon as
you get it using the standard
HTTP chunked
transfer encoding mechanism.
You could also stream data out
of the cloud using, again,
standard content-range
requests.
So it's very, very standard
HTTP compliant.
We also provide less standard,
because HTTP doesn't have a
protocol for this, the ability
to resume transfers, both
upload up and down.
For uploading data, this is
actually a very important
thing for a lot of
our customers.
Because when they build
applications which target end
users, and they want to allow
end users, for example, to
submit content-- let's say
you're building, I don't know,
an application that let's people
submit karaoke songs
that have people vote on them.
But you want to have end users
submit data to the cloud.
You want to make sure that if
they're on flaky connections,
which does sometimes happen,
perhaps they're taking a video
of themselves on their phone
in a karaoke bar at
1 o'clock at night.
You want to make sure that if
the video upload to the cloud
breaks off, it just resumes
where it left off.
And that's actually made
very easy by the
resumable transfer protocol.
We also make it very easy to
store and retrieve data to the
browser, again, because
we use standard HTTP
for all this stuff.
And we make it very easy to
authenticate the service using
either app Engine or
compute engine.
So if you're using compute
engine, you actually don't
have to worry about all the
steps required by the OAuth
standard to prove that you
are who you say you are.
The application container takes
care of that for you in
the background.
So you can actually just access
the service without
worrying OAuth at all.
Let's talk about one more aspect
of Cloud Storage which
I think is really important.
And we've actually spent a lot
of time working on making sure
you have, what's called, strong
data consistency.
And strong data consistency
means that when you write a
piece of data to the cloud from
anywhere in the world,
you want to make sure that you
or your end users anywhere in
the world get access to that
same piece of data
immediately.
Now the contrast is strong
data consistency versus
eventual consistency.
When you look at a lot of
distributed systems, there's
this term called eventual
consistency
which gets thrown around.
Which effectively means that
over time the entire system
reflects every update
made to it.
So to write a new piece of data
from Europe, and you try
to read it back from the US,
eventually the whole system
will have a consistent view of
what data exists in the cloud.
But in the short term, it could
look like your data
doesn't exist or you could see
an older version of the data.
And we think that's actually
a lot of complexity and can
cause all kinds of
interesting--
if your forensic analysis
is interesting--
but more often painful aspects
to the user experience.
So we want to make sure that
you can trust that once you
write your data in the cloud,
you could just read back
immediately from anywhere.
And hand in hand with that, we
actually provide you with the
ability to order your updates,
so that you could actually,
when you scale up and you have
a massive number of clients
reading and writing from the
cloud, you could make sure
that you know when multiple
people are trying to update
the same piece of data, which
update succeeded.
And so if you actually want
to do something like read,
modify, write, these two
characteristics are extremely
important, and they're
there for you.
Let's talk about sharing
and controlling
access to your data.
So we provide you with
mechanisms to provide access
control, or ACLs, over
all your data using
either groups or users.
So we often find that our
customers actually tend to
coalesce around group ACLs.
And the reason for that is
because when you share data
with groups of people, that's
actually the most natural
sharing mechanism.
You're often trying to share
data in a corporate
environments with other teams
the company, potentially your
customers, your partners.
If you're sharing data with
users, it's often I'm sharing
it with my family, not really
with one person.
And that also makes it much
easier when you think about
the composition of the group
you're sharing with changing.
So let's say you're implementing
a content
management system which lets
your graphic designers share
their data with the people
who are actually
putting up your website.
And let's say one of your
graphic artist decided to move
on over to the website design
team, so they get different
access control.
You just change the membership
of those two groups, and that
data flows through.
So it's actually much easier to
manage access to your data
where you could think about in
terms of groups of people and
who gets access to your data.
And to extend that and make that
even easier we actually
provide you with a mechanism
called the
default object ACLs.
So this is one of the nice
things you can do at a bucket
level is set up the default
access control on every new
piece of data which shows
up in a bucket.
So if you're actually creating
an internet share, so you're
sharing data with people all
over the internet, you can
just go in and set up the
default object ACLs when you
create the bucket.
And then from then onwards, the
data which shows up will
automatically have the
right permissions.
So you can control access,
set it up once, and then
forget about it.
We find that's really
powerful.
In some cases, you actually
don't want to focus on using
access control programmatically
and through a
declaration on the object.
You actually want to do that
dynamically in your
application.
And when you're trying to do
that, one thing we offer you
is the ability to actually
create what
we call Signed URLs.
So you effectively delegate
permission to any user who has
that special token for a limited
amount of time to act
on behalf of the person
who signed the URL.
And so you could, for example,
implement an application that
lets you sell premium content.
So let's say you're selling
music, you can give a person a
token that let's then download
the song they just bought for,
let's say, an hour.
And after that, if the URL
expired, they can come back
and get a new one.
So you control access to
your applications.
And finally we make
all this really
easy through the browser.
So if you actually hand out a
URL to a person, all Cloud
Storage access keys are URLs,
and you want them to be able
to access it from the browser,
all they do is to log in with
their account, they prove to us
that they're the person who
they say they are, they have
access to the object, and they
can download it.
So it's very easy to do this
both programmatically and
through the browser.
So I've talked a bit about some
of the key aspects of the
service, and I hope that at
this point in time you're
already beginning to have some
ideas about how you can use
the service.
One of the ways, actually here
are a few the ways in which
our customers use the service.
Everything from content serving,
you saw me give a
demonstration of that with the
JavaScript web app all the way
up to actually storing it in the
cloud and then making use
of Google's computation
technology.
So actually taking the data
they've uploaded into Cloud
Storage, and then using services
like Google Big Query
to do multi terabyte scale SQL
queries on data in close real
time, which is actually a really
powerful tool when you
think about it.
Or using our machine learning
tools, and everything in
between, so you can move your
data, your data backups, and
your archives in the cloud, make
them available to people
over the internet.
You can use it for
data sharing.
I talked about a few of
those examples of when
that might be useful.
Or you can use it for any
generic storage for any
application you build, so if
you're building a photo
sharing app, which interestingly
you'll see in a
few minutes, you can use it
to store your photographs.
So we announced cloud
storage in general
availability at I/O last year.
And we've been hard at work
delivering several features
that you've asked us for.
So thank you for the feature
requests, and
please keep them coming.
We'll also talk about two things
that are new today.
The ability to serve an entire
site, as you just
saw for a while ago.
We'll actually show you the code
to make that happen, and
faster access to your server
access log, so you can
actually perform much faster
analysis on who's using your
application and how.
And then we're also going to
talk about some great new
technology that we're going
to ship very soon.
We're going to give you
a taste of that.
Some of that is going to
be available in limited
availability today.
And some of it is going to
be completely new, and
will come out son.
So to talk about all that in the
context of an application,
I'd like to invite
Nathan Herring.
NATHAN HERRING: Thanks,
Navneet.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how you can use
Cloud Storage in your
application, and I'm going to
demonstrate this with
a little lab.
So you've been working late at
night, trading ideas for your
next million dollar software
project with your venture
capitalists, and you've got
it, you've got the idea.
You have the customers, they
have the data, and you can
provide the value
added service.
Well we're going to show you
how to use Cloud Storage to
take end user uploads, take
action on the data they
provide you, and then serve that
data back to them as well
as take a look at how people
are using your service.
And for that I'm going to
switch over to a demo.
What Navneet showed you a little
bit before is this
simple photo gallery.
All of the images you're seeing
here are being served
directly to your customers
from Cloud Storage, not
through your website.
In addition, we have an upload
tab, which you can do it right
here on your Macintosh or you
could have it run in your
Android browser.
Either way a user can quickly
put their important data-- in
this case, we're using
a photograph--
hit upload, and it goes
directly to the cloud.
It Does not go through
your website.
Once you're done we can return
to the gallery, and all a
sudden we have our new picture
here in the cloud along with
all the other data.
So I'm going to tell
you a little bit
how we put this together.
The first thing I'm going
to talk about is
storing end user data.
The first technology we use to
allow people to have access to
Cloud Storage in this
demonstration, is we use
signed post policies.
That, in combination with Signed
URLs, that's something
that Navneet was talking a
little earlier about let's you
do very specific delegation of
your access to edit items in a
bucket or add new objects to
a bucket to your customers.
They don't even have to be
Google account holders.
They can just get the URL that
you give them and use it.
In the case of downloads, it's a
matter of signing a piece of
data that says, what is the
action you want to take?
And what is the specific
bucket and
object you want to access?
And you could make some other
assertions as well.
Once you sign that, you add that
to the URL, and pass that
entire URL to customer.
In this case, we're actually
using Signed POST policies,
which is an HTML form post,
which we then say you're
supposed to upload this specific
object with these
access controls, and you can
make other assertions as well.
Like Navneet said, this is a
great way to deliver things
like a temporary time
bomb downloads.
It's also a great way to be
able to have users upload
their data to cloud.
and there's more information,
you can find it at the access
control link at the bottom.
The second technology we're
using here in this
demonstration is Cross-Origin
Resource Sharing,
also known as CORS.
It's really actually letting the
browser do its job to keep
you safe and secure.
You really don't
want to have--
when you have a website that's
operating with a third party
website, you don't want to
have malicious iframes
stealing your data and sending
it to tracking websites or
vice versa, branding your
data as their own.
So what browsers will do
normally, will keep your site
from accessing that third party
site, unless you tell it
you're one of the good guys.
In our case what you could do
is, you can configure in a
bucket in Cloud Storage to have
CORS configuration saying
that your app spot app or your
other web application is a
friend of yours.
So what happens in the browser
world, is the browser sends a
preflight request, and we say
why yes, you are in fact
allowed to send requests.
And then Chrome or your other
browsers will allow Form
posts, which is what we
do in our application.
Or you can use JavaScript
XMLHttp requests, and they
don't get blocked.
Another thing that's always
important when you're thinking
about having your users upload
data to the cloud is getting
the right access controls
on things.
And there are some helpful group
mechanisms things that
we have that will let you do
some management of this.
Every bucket belongs to an API
project, and API projects come
with three groups
automatically.
They have an owner's, editors,
and viewers.
And buckets by default and
objects that are created in
them have those groups
attached to them.
So if you have a homogeneous set
of buckets in a project,
you can certainly use those
to control your access.
But if you have per-bucket
custom configuration, it's
really easy to set up
a Google group to
manage all your users.
Groups can contain individual
users like actual emails of
your customers, or they
could be things
like service accounts.
In any case, once you've set up
whatever groups you want to
set up, you can then specify
access controls on your
uploaded objects.
There are a number of
pre-configured, pre-defined
access control lists
like Public
Read or Project Private.
And you can specify those in
your upload request with the
xgoogle ACL request header.
And that is another thing that
you can, in your form post
policy, say that you must post
with this access control.
The other thing that the
Navneet talked about is
default object access
controls.
They're really handy.
Once you set it up, but you
can give every new object
exactly the access controls
you want.
So next, you've had your users
upload their data into the
cloud, and now you want to
serve it back to them and
serve some more.
So first we're going to talk
a little bit about how our
little application works.
This is a tiny little snippet of
JavaScript that runs in the
client in the browser.
What we end up doing is, when
we load we ask your website
what are the objects in cloud
storage you want to render?
And it passes back a little
blob of JSON, and we parse
that and use it to build up
direct URL all links as either
anchor tags or image source
tags, and then render those by
putting them in the DOM.
You can see an example
at the bottom.
So between the boilerplate of
this lovely library called the
Twitter Bootstrap Library, all
we had to do in terms of code
and JavaScript and App Engine
was about four pages worth of
code, and this is just
a little part of it.
But why even have your
own separate website?
You can just run it in
Google cloud storage.
Today we are releasing the
ability to configure a bucket
as a website.
And we have two properties
of a bucket that
control how this works.
The first one is this idea
of a directory page.
So when a user browses to the
bucket or some directory like
object inside the bucket, they
don't get a strange error
message saying, this
object isn't found.
Instead, what we do is we go and
look for this sub-object.
In this case, we're looking
at example.com/index.html.
And if you have placed an
object called index.html
there, we will serve
that to the user.
This allows the website demo
that Navneet put up a little
before by letting that
particular GCS demo bucket
point directly to an object
that then served up the
JavaScript.
And this works for sub
directories too.
So you can express
directory-like quality inside
of your bucket in the website.
The other interesting piece
of this is you can have
a custom 404 page.
And this is just a top level
object that you point to, and
if the original object could not
be found or the directory
object could not be found,
we'll render this.
And both of these objects can
have their own custom
JavaScript in them.
So you can do much more than
just serve static content.
You can figure out what request
was being asked, and
maybe do some logging, or
perhaps provide alternatives,
redirects, it's really
up to you.
Here we have a little
bit of XML.
This is the request you would
do to set that in.
It's also available via the
GSUtil command line
application that Navneet
showed before.
So now that we have users
uploading their data into the
cloud and we're serving it
back to them, we need to
figure out some way to actually
take action on this
uploaded data.
So we have the flow, right?
The customer hits upload, it
doesn't go to the application,
it goes to Cloud Storage, but
then we need to do things like
create the thumbnails and
render the galleries.
And there's some magic that
happens between step one and
two, and that's what I'd like
to talk about today.
Traditional web applications
would often have you do a
redirect after a post or have a
second web request that gets
sent to the main application
to say, hey,
something new has happened.
Well that's putting the burden
of responsibility on the
client, which is not where
you want to be.
The other, alternative polling,
is even worse.
But today we are going to show
you what's coming up next,
notifications in
Cloud Storage.
In order to set up
notifications, you need to
have full control
over the bucket.
But once you do,
you basically--
for example, if you're using a
service account representing
your application, you can put
the email address of that
service account directly
into the asset control
list for the bucket.
In this case we were using an
App Engine application, but it
doesn't have to be.
And you might find that the
email address is instead
developer@gservers.com.
But once you've set that up, the
next thing you have to do
is actually perform
the subscription.
And here we have some code that
says, well we want the
full control over this bucket.
And we have two relevant URLs.
The first one is the actually
subscription URL.
And you could see that your
bucket name is baked right
into that URL.
The second is a call back URL.
This is the URL that you build
that Cloud Storage will turn
around and call you
on with the data
of what's been updated.
You can see here that we're
actually using that service
account we just mentioned
directly from app engine's
ability to get access
tokens out of this.
If you're not using App Engine,
it's a simple matter
of downloading the private key
for the service account, and
using that to get your tokens.
Once have the two URLs
of interest and the
authorization, you run a
fetch, a get, at this
particular URL.
We use the xsubscibe header with
the hook that you want.
And if you get a successful
response, a 200rit response
back, then you're all set.
So now what do you
get out of this?
Well, you're going to get a BLOB
of JSON that says, this
is what's changed.
This is a smaller example than
what you'd actually see.
But generally speaking, right
now I think we only return one
object, but it's possible
we might
batch them in the future.
But here's an example of some of
the metadata that you might
see about an object.
You can see the content type,
the MD5 hash, the owner, which
in this case is the
ID of the user.
So now all you have left is to
add a response handler in your
App Engine app or your other
application to import that
JSON and read the metadata
fields out of it.
And then now you can add it to
your task queue, you can set
up Google pipelines to perform
all sorts of operations on
that data, do whatever
you want.
You add the value at this point
and can profit by it.
So now that we've got this
excellent application out
there, we're photo sharing away,
people are uploading all
their images, people are viewing
their images, you have
a whole lot of people using your
service, and you might
want to know what's going on.
The Google Cloud Storage
provides usage logs to help
you figure out what's
going on.
We're going to talk about
two parts here.
The first is configuring your
bucket to produce the access
and storage logs.
The second is how you might be
able to use Google Big Query
to perform some analysis.
The first part of setting this
up is, you need to have a
second bucket.
This is so that there isn't a
causal loop, so your access
logs cause more access logs.
But you basically create a
second bucket, and you grant
write access to that bucket
to our service,
our analytic service.
This is an example of how to set
up that configuration on
example.com to say, please log
all storage and access for
this bucket into the
logs.example.com.
We also provide the ability
to have a prefix.
So you can have many, many
buckets share the same logging
bucket and differentiate
by the prefix.
The other thing I should also
mention is that a default
object ACL here is pretty
critical, because you get
whatever that is.
When Cloud Storage Analytics
writes a new object in there
it will just inherit the ACLs
that are already in there.
Then once you to set that up the
logs bucket will get logs
in it, and then it's just a
pretty straightforward matter
to import that data
into Big Query.
And we'll have some examples
up on our document site.
But once you're in big query,
you can do things like SQL
statements over the objects
that people are serving.
And it seems that we have a
really popular photo that
people downloaded lots of times
called Bool's cats.
Well your mileage may vary.
But you can see that like you
can slice and dice this data
anyway you want.
So remember that little blob
of JSON that came in the
notifications?
Well that came from
a new in-point
we're introducing today.
Today Google Cloud Storage
joins the rest of the
discovery based APIs that
we offer here at Google.
We have a new set of
JSON-specific end points that
are specifically geared towards
working with the
number of API client libraries
that Google supports.
So here, again, is a little
more metadata.
This is some sample metadata
what a bucket would look like.
We have here the project ID, the
time was created, the all
important location, whether it's
in the US or in Europe.
There are some other things are
not mention here like the
default object ACLs, the ACLs.
One thing about this new API
is that you can set all of
these things in one update
or one insert operation.
That's kind of neat.
So there are some improvements
that we get from producing a
discovery based API.
And you may have heard some of
these in some of the API
talks, because they're common
across Google technologies.
One is the idea of being able
to patch metadata you don't
now have to edit all of
the buckets options.
You don't have to edit all of
the objects little pieces of
metadata like content type or
encoding if you want to change
just one thing
And metadata patch allows
you to do this.
It basically lets you use the
patch verb and specify only a
tiny little blob of
JSON which is the
thing you want to change.
It also allows you to
do metadata batch.
Which is, if you need to make an
operation on a whole number
of objects, you can do
that all at once.
It also lets you access
objects and other
APIs at the same time.
Another thing that we've
introduced here is this idea
of access controls
as a collection.
And it lets you do things like
line item access controls.
Instead of having to do a read,
modify, write kind of
form of editing your access
controls, you can say please
give this user read access.
And it will just add that.
But the most important thing,
really, is the fact that we
now can take advantage of
Google's API awesome API
client libraries.
And available now are all these
languages and there's
more support coming.
This is all happening in limited
availability, so you
should stay tuned to find out
how you can get involved.
So there are some things that
we weren't able to fit into
our demonstration app, and I'd
like to talk about them now.
One of the things that
happens when you're
operating at scale--
although we don't show this
with our web service
application or our photo
gallery application.
But if you have a whole bunch of
your servers all talking to
Cloud Storage and all working
on the same objects, either
because you are reading an
object, working on it, perhaps
editing that object in place,
or because you're doing
content delivery of all of us
form, and want to make sure
that you only update objects
when you have to.
There are some tools
that we have to
allow concurrency control.
Those are the two major
ways of doing it.
If you are doing a read, modify,
write, it's really
nice to be able to use
the traditional HTTP
preconditioners of If match,
or if unmodified sense.
That way when you've done the
read other object data, you
can then do your work on it, and
only commit it if someone
has not messed with your object
from behind your back.
So the reverse which is the how
do you caching, is you can
ask, hey, Cloud Storage
give this to me, but
only if it's changed.
And for that you'd want
if none match,
or if modified since.
We also have some custom
HEP-preconditioned headers
that re used with a copy
in the cloud operation.
And you can mix and
match these.
So you can say only copy this
object if it hasn't changed
from the last time inspected,
and only put it over here if
that object hasn't changed since
last time inspected.
This allows you to be able to be
very careful about how you
do object updates and,
not lose any data.
But another way that we're going
to introduce today as a
technology preview to not lose
data is object versioning.
Very soon now you'll be able
to turn on the bucket
configuration such that when
you over right or delete an
object, that object does not go
away, it's kept around in
the service.
Each of these objects
contain their own
set of mutable metadata.
So you can go to an older object
and change the access
controls on it to be private
to your organization.
And so on only your customers
get to read the latest.
Or you can fix errors in
your older objects.
But the best thing is that
you can go back.
So you no longer have
to provide backup
services for yourself.
You can just go back to the
data that you had in the
cloud, and it will be
right there for you.
So we've talked about a
bunch of stuff here
today for Cloud Storage.
There's a whole bunch of things
you can use right now.
You can use access and storage
logs by configuring your
bucket to render those.
You can use Signed URLs and
post queries to allow
delegated access to customers
to use Cloud Storage.
Cross origin resource sharing
to ensure that your browser
can go directly to us as a
third party site without
preventing you through
security options.
Buckets as a website, default
object access controls, and
concurrency controls--
we also are introducing the
discovery based version of the
API, and you can request access
up at the console.
That will get turned
on, if not right
now, than later today.
And you can right now get
started by reading the
documentation or playing with it
the API's explorer, and we
highly suggest that you do so.
And you've seen a couple of
things are coming out
imminently at our technology
preview.
We have notifications which lets
you subscribe to changes
happening in your buckets so
you can operate exactly in
time without polling,
and object versions.
If you're interested in Cloud
Storage and want to know
what's going on, I highly
suggest that you sign up at GS
announce to get whenever we
release new features.
And give us feedback.
Join us at
GSdiscussion@googlegroups.com
and tell us what you like, what
you don't like, what you
want to see.
Really, it's you're guys'
feedback on how our API works
that helps us figure out what
we need to do next.
And as always there's a sign up
link at the bottom, you can
go there, set yourself up,
and get rolling with
Google Cloud Storage.
So for those of you who did not
see some of these related
sessions at Google I/O, I
highly recommend them.
They'll be broadcast through
recording on YouTube.
But Building Data Pipelines
At Google Scale
is an awesome talk.
It talks about how you can use
MapReduce using cloud storage,
and also provides the ability
to do workflows to move data
from whatever data store you
might have through Google
Cloud Storage to be analyzed
by Big Query.
The second one it's interesting,
if you want to
think about the authentication
aspects of using cloud
storage-- especially
service accounts--
is a OAuth 2.0 for identity
and data access.
You should have a link
here, and eventually
those will get posted.
I Highly suggest you
take a look.
And that's about it.
We'd like to thank you for
coming here and listening to
us talk about our service.
We're really excited that you
guys are going to use us to
hook up all of your web apps,
Google Cloud Engine, Google
App Engine, we're just happy
that you're here.
You can find more information
up at
developers.google.com/storage.
We are available directly
at gs/team@google.com.
You can always reach us.
You can ask questions
on stack overflow.
The tag we have is
google-cloud-storage.
My name's Nathan.
This is Navneet.
At this point I'd
love to invite
you all to ask questions.
If you go to the microphones, we
won't have to repeat it for
the recorded audience.
So, thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have
some questions.
If you could share some
information on performance--
sorry, IOPS performance.
And also the latency
of getting the
data on Edge servers.
I'm just wondering if I replace
my source solution
with yours, and I'm using
Akamai, for example, what type
of performance I would expect.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So let me answer
them in reverse order.
So we do a lot of performance
optimization in Cloud Storage.
I won't necessarily say that
you can replace Akamai with
Cloud Storage, but what I would
say is give it a try.
We actually have a free trial
tier, so you can stick some
data in there, serve it out,
see how it goes for you.
In many cases we found our
customers find that, because
of the really good performance
we provide, they don't
necessarily need a CVM,
so I encourage you
to give it a try.
To answer the first question,
it's a cloud storage service.
It's built on Google
infrastructure and scales to
the levels Google need it to,
so in terms of IOPS I think
you are unlikely to hit any
limitations in service.
NATHAN HERRING: There are some
things that-- we do have Edge
servers of our own.
And depending on how you have
your access control set up,
it's entirely possible that we
can provide really excellent
performance by caching
at the edges.
AUDIENCE: Is that included
in the storage?
Is caching something
that you get with--
NATHAN HERRING: Caching is, you
get it for free, but they
have to be public objects.
If they're not public objects
that require authentication,
then we don't know that you
can cache it, so we don't.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
When you're uploading, is there
a way to monitor the
progress from some--
NATHAN HERRING: Oh, sure.
The way that we had i tin our
JavaScript was pretty
simplified, but reasonable
uploads are set up so that you
can monitor the progress
directly.
But there are some browsers that
don't let you do that,
and you're allowed
to chunk uploads.
Even though it's not usually
desirable, but the best
performance is create a
resumable session to upload,
and then post as much as you can
until your either done or
the internet breaks.
But you can always break it up
into sections to say, I posted
this much, report progress.
I posted this much,
report progress.
AUDIENCE: What I was really
asking was, I have a similar
app already, and what
I'm thinking is--
can I from JavaScript, from
the browser can I say hey,
what percentage does
this have, so I
could show the user.
NATHAN HERRING: I believe so.
I'd have to go back and look
at the JavaScript well--.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So find is
afterwards, we'll talk through
this in detail.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
when we can expect this to be
available to Google
Apps accounts.
I kind of tried it with my
Google Apps account, and it
didn't seem to work.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Find us
afterwards, it should work
with apps accounts right now.
AUDIENCE: OK, can we do
billing through--
if we have a Premier account
for App Engine,
does that tie through?
NAVNEET JONEJA: Currently
Premier accounts are separate
from Cloud Storage and App
Engine, but you could actually
get a Premiere account
for storage as well.
AUDIENCE: I have a two
part question.
OK, the first one is, how
are things like--
and maybe that was a
session on this--
databases handled
in the cloud?
And the second part of that
question is, have you heard
any horror stories or anything
or examples of how people have
dealt with things like Oracle
licensing when trying to put
things in the cloud?
Because I know they love
licensing things by core.
NAVNEET JONEJA: that's
a great question.
So in terms of the performance
characteristics you need from
databases, it turns out that
because you're actually trying
to typically insert small pieces
of data with random
access reads and writes, it's
not really suited for the kind
of service we have
at Cloud Storage.
But we do have a sister service
called Google Cloud
SQL which allows you to do MySQL
databases in the Google
Cloud fully managed.
So I would check that out if you
want to post your database
in the Cloud Storage.
There was also a talk yesterday
about the battle of
back ends, which was basically
comparing relational database
like MySQL with the NoSQL
database like the app Engine
data store.
So that's what I would
talk about in terms
of structured data.
To answer your question about
Oracle and licensing, we don't
actually currently have
something that does Oracle, so
within Cloud Storage that's not
within the Google Cloud
Ecosystem yet. that isn't really
question we can answer.
AUDIENCE: I've just hot a
question about the persistent
storage in the new
compute engine.
Could you share, I guess, a bit
of the differences that
you guys are seeing or planning
from a strategic
perspective?
It seems like the bucket
metaphor versus maybe the
database, sort of sand metaphor
is probably the main
one, but I was wondering
if you could
answer or speak to that.
As well, I was wondering whether
Speedy is something
that you guys have enabled from
a HTTP delivery point of
view coming out of
Google Storage.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So let me see.
Two questions you asked were,
first is, can you
differentiate between the
synthesis and disk?
And second is, do you think of
persistent disk as being
something that could potentially
offer HTTP end
point to Cloud Storage?
AUDIENCE: No, the
second question
was completely unrelated.
I was really just asking about
Speedy, that HTTP extension
that can pipeline requests.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So that's
a great question.
So let me answer the first
question first.
In terms of the access models,
think about Google Cloud
Storage as being an internet
object store.
So it's really fundamentally
targeted at storing objects,
which are logical entities,
and actually using that in
your applications when they
actually only care about the
object, the entity.
It's really focused at that
really high availability,
reliable performance, HTTP
access, all that good stuff.
Let's assume Disk is a lower
level service, it's basically
a block device.
Great performance, you mount
it from compute engine as a
disk, and then you could do
things like, for example, as
you mentioned run a
database on it.
The kind of use cases you
implement on them are different.
They're also complimentary,
because it turns out that you
don't always want to store
everything on a persistent
disk and manage that yourself.
You could store that data
in Cloud Storage.
AUDIENCE: And the Speedy
dimension?
NAVNEET JONEJA: I actually don't
have an answer for you
on that, but find me afterwards,
and I'll see if I
can find the answer for you.
AUDIENCE: Do the object versions
have a specific
lifetime that they last, or do
they just last forever and
just count against
your storage?
And is there an easy way to
purge older versions?
NATHAN HERRING: This is not
entirely formed yet, but
you'll be able to purge
individual versions.
It's probable that we will have
some expiration that you
could set on it, or like keep
inversions, but it is not out
yet, so we will take that
under consideration.
AUDIENCE: My question
is more--
I guess could you comment a
little bit more on what I
consider kind of a Federated
token, where my application is
really a broker of identity
between some internal systems
and Google Cloud Storage?
So I saw that you support post
forms that I authenticate, but
what if my posting is very
different than my reads?
And how do I--
first of all, does it support
all the verbs?
Does it support patch?
What if I only want to upload
part of the file?
If I have a file on Google Cloud
Storage, and say it's 5
terabytes of data, and I only
want to patch it with another
gig of data, can
this, I guess--
I call it Federated Tokens,
because that's the equivalent
on the Amazon side--
support that?
And does the read semantics
or your get verb--
can you have different ACLs or a
group extensions or some way
to manage identities for
different verbs, and I guess
can you talk a little
bit more about that?
And how would you create sort
of this broker of identity
between some internal systems
and Google cloud storage?
So that a client would come to
you, you would get a token
that would say, put in the HTTP
headers, and then the
client can actually directly
connect to Google Cloud
Storage as opposed to coming
back to the application, and
the application uploading
it to cloud storage.
Does that make sense?
NAVNEET JONEJA: I think I get
the gist of your question.
Let me see if I understand.
So I think what you're looking
for is some mechanism for you
to provide a token
to Cloud Storage.
And Cloud Storage looks at that
token in the request and
say, is this valid?
And because you provided
that token, it's valid.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So Signed URL
is a kind of a form of that.
Because you essentially come to
us with your assigned URL,
you delegate access to a given
object on any of the verbs.
So all the verbs we have
are supported.
And if a person shows up with
that URL, which is essentially
a tokenized URL, they
get access to data.
If not, they don't.
So that's the form
we support today.
We don't have a more complex
system where we actually
integrate with authenticity
on site.
We don't have that right now.
The second question you asked
was patching data.
We don't actually support
patching the
core object data today.
It's all right on the
semantics right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NATHAN HERRING: So to elaborate
a little bit, we do
allow things like App Engine to
have users log in and then
provide their credentials
to an App Engine app.
Or you can do it via the API
client libraries, and then
they get the token
for themselves.
And then they can access Google
Cloud Storage as if
they are themselves.
So depending on how you have
access controls set up in your
objects, that might suit
your purposes.
AUDIENCE: Now it was more
for non-Google--
I guess for people that don't
have a Gmail account.
It was more for if you have a
bunch of internal systems.
NATHAN HERRING: Gmail accounts
actually are not, strictly
speaking, required.
Anyone with any email account
at all can have a Google
account attached
to that email.
And then you can--
if you add that they can
basically get an invitation to
come and use the service.
But if you don't want to do
that, then yes, you're kind of
in the model of providing
delegated access as if they
are you or some identity that
you've said, please act as
this person.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So could you comment
on as a service, which
consistency availability, and
petition, which two you're
emphasis is on.
NAVNEET JONEJA: You're talking
about the CAP theorem.
So that's a really interesting
question.
It deserves an in detail offline
answer from us, so if
you want to talk about
it more, let's
talk about it offline.
At a high level, if you could go
and look up research on the
web, you'll find that there's
actually someone who proved
that the Cap theorem
only holds at a
given point of time.
In other words at a given point
of time, consistency,
partition tolerance, and
availability are sort of like
the three ends of the
triangle you can't
hold at the same time.
It turns out that you can, for a
fraction of a second let one
corner up and then push
it back down again.
So there actually are
ways to do stuff.
I'm not going to go into the
secret sauce of what we do,
but the answer is we really
try to do all three.
AUDIENCE: Sam's creating yet
another photo sharing app, and
with the idea that all the
photos that are added are to
be shared publicly--
so a user adds photos to albums,
and then they get
shared to the worldwide web.
And say all my users already
have Google accounts and they
all have Picasso Web, should I
implement that using their
Picasso web albums?
Or should I use Google Cloud
Storage to have them--
should I save their photos to
Google Cloud Storage instead?
Instead of having them create
albums in Picasso Web and then
sharing them?
NAVNEET JONEJA: So that's
a great question.
So I think answer to that
question really depends on who
owns the data.
So if you want your applications
to own the data,
and you basically want your
application to be able to
manage the data, control the
data, let's say you want to
do, for example, you want
to be able to manage--
in terms of service adherence--
you want to
prevent people from uploading
other things
that are not images.
If you want to have control over
the data, you probably
want to use Cloud Storage.
If what you want is to have
people tell Google, this is my
data, and your application
accesses it indirectly as sort
of a layer above the storage,
then you're looking at
something like Drive
or Picasso.
So that's kind of the models.
If you have user controlled
storage, get Drive or Picasso.
If you have application owned
and controlled storage, you
get Cloud Storage.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is on
setting custom headers.
If you set a bucket as a
website, can use set the cross
domain origin header?
And for objects, can use set
metadata such as Gzip content?
NAVNEET JONEJA: So Metadata, we
do support setting of the
content encoding header.
That's actually a slightly more
complicated discussion,
so let's have that
offline as well.
But we do support setting it.
The first question was--
NATHAN HERRING: It sounded like,
if you wanted to have a
cross origin resource
sharing when you're
using a static website.
AUDIENCE: Right, if I set the
bucket as a website, can I
trust another domain?
NATHAN HERRING: Right, and so if
that website you're serving
up say links to an app spot or
your other website over there,
it's really up to that other
websites to support the CORS
configurations.
So your browser is going to do
the preflight request to the
other place.
If you're just doing it to
another bucket, then that
other bucket could have CORS
configuration set on it to
allow this and--
you can do a lot with
CORS configuration.
AUDIENCE: Yes, say my third
party website is doing the
session authentication, let's
say session management, but
I'm storing all my thumbnails
on your site, than I'd
probably need CORS header
on your site.
NATHAN HERRING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And you guys
set that CORS.
NATHAN HERRING: You get
to control that.
AUDIENCE: You can?
NATHAN HERRING: So it's a
configuration on the bucket,
and you can set that up.
And there's some documentation
up on my website, and I
entreat you to take a look.
AUDIENCE: Yesterday at the
Google Drive demonstration, if
I upload pictures, I get optical
character recognition,
for example, find
all the pictures
in Germany or whatever.
Do I have a similar
ability here?
NAVNEET JONEJA: Not right now.
That kind of brings into light
the difference between the two
services, right?
Cloud Storage is really focused
at giving you storage
for your applications.
It's really focused on storage
and the related features that
you need from the
storage layer.
Drive is much more end user
focused, and has those
additional features.
Which is not to say that if
you come and ask us for
certain features, we won't
implement them, but that's
kind of the dichotomy of how we
think about these services.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NATHAN HERRING: Anybody else?
All right, we'd like to thank
you again for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]